all right we've got plenty of questions
to answer on this friday edition of pft
live opening up the mailbag and right
out of the gates our good friend ayred
zimmernowk who's been asking questions
for a decade now to pft live in its
various forms who will be the biggest
loser in this ongoing drama in houston
the texans or desean watson peter we
haven't talked about desean watson today
obviously things have changed
dramatically since the last time you
were on with me and especially because
it was a pft pm maybe even before any of
the stuff hit the fan in houston
where do you think this currently stands
by way of watson or the texans losing
more in the long run
they've all been napalmed
every single one in the organization
you know
look at the texans as a football team
mike
the texans are an expansion team
they just signed about 900 people in
free agency nobody has ever heard of
and you know and you look at what's
going on with their team
and this is going to be i mean thank god
for them that jacksonville's in the
division at least for one more year
uh you know maybe they'll be able to win
one of the games against jacksonville
who knows
but
but i guess i look at this mike and say
this team
really took a huge hit
because of the disaffection
uh
you know of of what happened in essence
with deshaun watson but again look
deshawn watson is in a significant
amount of trouble
you know legally right now right now
it's only civil cases could it graduate
to criminal cases we'll see
but
his reputation
is you know as we speak
you know he's the guy on the back of the
horse
who has fallen off the horse and the
horse just keeps running as the guy is
uh
you know is driven is is just basically
ridden along in the dirt
and so
i kind of look at this and say everybody
is lost
i i don't know how to quantify who has
lost more
but as of now i think everybody is a
giant loser in houston
and peter one thing that i want to
emphasize to the extent that folks
missed this earlier in the week the
possibility for criminal prosecution
right now i believe is low
because prosecutors typically don't like
to take on cases that they think they
have a good chance of losing and it's
difficult to prove guilt beyond a
reasonable doubt in a case where you've
got the testimony from one witness
and you've got
contradicting testimony from another
witness and even without that accused
testifying if he exercises his right
against self-incrimination
the story of the accuser can often be
sufficiently questioned and undermined
to raise reasonable doubt doesn't take
much to create reasonable doubt skilled
defense lawyers can do that but the
problem for watson is even if there
isn't enough now
to proceed against him with a criminal
charge that a prosecutor would feel good
about
resulting in a conviction
if these civil cases go forward he's got
a hell of a decision to make because if
you take the fifth in the context of the
civil case which you have the right to
do before the criminal cases are filed
or resolved while there's still the
possibility of criminal jeopardy
you're going to lose the civil case
think about it the person who's accusing
you gets on the witness stand tells a
story and your response is to say i
invoke my right against
self-incrimination you're losing that
case every one of those cases where you
do that well the other side of it is if
you allow yourself to be cross-examined
by tony busby aggressively twisted into
knots because he's skilled
at twisting people into knots and you've
never testified before and you're in
your mid-20s and you have no idea where
any of this is going and the next thing
you know you've created a transcript
that becomes a blueprint that a
prosecutor can take and make his or her
case easier that's the
the problem that's the ultimate dilemma
desean watson faces and that's why i've
been saying hey the best move is
have your reckoning
make things right
whatever it is that you did or didn't do
you've got 16 and up to 24 people who
think you did something you shouldn't
have done get everybody in a room get a
retired judge there to serve as a
mediator and work all this out because
otherwise peter this is going to hover
over him
the texans and more importantly the nfl
for a year year and a half two years and
it's only going to make the nfl upset
and create a bigger consequence for
watson on the back end his best play
make this all go away and i don't mean
do it in a way that is unfair to the
individuals it has to take into account
their concerns
it has to make them feel like they've
had their day in court and they have to
be reasonably satisfied with the outcome
as it relates to them
yeah i think now mike you know the more
immediate question is
what do you do if you are a team
maybe the jets maybe miami maybe
carolina what do you do if you're a team
that had legitimate interest in desean
watson there's absolutely nothing you
can do and so therefore
the reason why in my opinion
that look
the timing is never good for a case as
sorted and ugly as this
but the reason why this timing is
incredibly bad
is because
what's gonna happen you know i would say
the three biggest candidates
right now in order would be carolina
uh
miami and the new york jets in that
order okay and if that is the case
right
every one of those teams very well
could move on
from desean watson
uh
in the month of april what happens if
mac jones lasts till number eight which
he probably will
and if
the panthers who have been really
you know disguising their interest in
mac jones
mike tannenbaum had him on my podcast a
couple of weeks ago
and he said he would bet me anything uh
some starbucks thing he bet me anything
that mac jones does not get past number
eight
you know
and and he was he was certain he was
just had absolute certainty about it so
but all i'm saying is
when they take if they take a
quarterback at number eight
right so then they're out of the race
for
deshaun watson and similarly if tuatanga
veloa plays and plays well this fall
they're out of the race
for deshaun watson and i don't think the
jets i think the jets are a distant
third because i don't think they're
going to trade for i didn't think they
were going to trade for deshaun watson
going into this but
take all of those things and now where's
the market
san francisco maybe
uh i mean and and what is somebody going
to pay
for a tarnished player
like desean watson you know
and again i say tarnished player
and there could be a way
that none of
this none of these accusations are true
we simply don't know
but
really mike you've been involved in this
from both sides from the media side and
the legal side you know
that no matter what happens there is
going to be a tarnish on desean watson
yeah and i think one way that you can
begin to repair
the damage is resolve the matters in a
way that is
satisfactory to the people who have the
grievances that have been reduced to a
civil complaint but when we say make
this go away there's nothing nefarious
there it means resolve it fix it
find a way to make those individuals
happy and then you move forward with
your redemption the redemption's going
to come at some point a redemption came
from mike vick a redemption will come
but
part of getting your redemption is you
you you've got it you've got to take
your reckoning and pay your penance
whatever it may be my concern for
deshaun watson is the more he fights the
more he digs in the longer this lasts
the worse it's going to be and even if
it does get resolved today
there's that question that an
organization is going to have to ask do
we do business with this individual
from a pr standpoint everything's about
pr as far as the nfl and its teams are
concerned are we comfortable doing
business with desean watson some teams
some cities some states it may
be easier than others these are all
complicated decisions and questions that
need to be resolved by the various teams
i just think that
everyone is better off
if desean watson recognizes
that
there's a problem that needs to be
resolved and there's no magic wand he
can wave to resolve it it's not going to
go away and if he fights it it's going
to last a long time and the best thing
that he can do at this point
is make it right for the individuals who
are lining up with these complaints and
i know they're frustrated they don't
know who they are because they all file
under the name jane doe
the complaints
make it pretty clear dates and times and
places you should be able to figure out
who they are and if it's immaterial
bring them all together you'll find out
who they are when you have your
mediation session and you try to make it
right with each one of them to me
that's the best play and that's the only
way to have this cleared up before the
2021 season begins and even then peter
he still may be suspended without pay
for a certain number of games to start
the year but at least it's not going to
be a situation where he's on paid leave
for a whole year like an adrian peterson
or greg hardy were in 2014. that's part
of the problem here and that's a great
irony he's never going to play for the
texans again that's what john mcclane
says well you know what the only way he
may get paid this year is to be on the
texans because he's on paid leave
and the texans are paying him 10 million
dollars while all this other stuff keeps
going so this is a mess for everyone
and the sooner that the legal cases are
resolved the sooner it
it is a mess that is cleaned up for
everyone
mike can i can i just add one last thing
to this i think there is a great
lesson to be learned you mentioned
michael vick
and and michael vick basically
found a second life in the nfl he didn't
find it in atlanta but he found it in
philadelphia and he redeemed so much
about himself with his work in this
second life but i will never ever forget
when he told me when he got out of
prison
and i wrote this for sports illustrated
that one of the things that
haunted is too strong a word but when he
was sitting
in leavenworth you know the kansas
prison when he was sitting in
leavenworth uh you know sent there as a
uh as a sentenced to dog fighting
charges when he was sitting there one of
the things that kept coming in his head
is
how am i going to face roger goodell
how am i going to
i swore to roger goodell that these
charges were trumped up you know there
was nothing to him i never did this i
had nothing to do with dog fighting how
am i going to do this
and so
that is something honestly that in my
opinion and look i am not saying in any
way that desean watson is guilty but i
what i am saying is that
if
there are things that desean watson
feels he is culpable in
the best thing that he could do right
now
i believe is exactly what you say
he's gotta he's gotta come clean and
he's gotta talk about all of this stuff
uh either privately with his accusers or
you know if he is absolutely convinced
he's being ramrodded and you know you
want the truth to come out then i guess
you fight it but in my opinion
you know
he's got to make sure
that he doesn't say anything right now
that he's truly going to regret later on
i mean the bottom line is he was engaged
in activities that put him in a position
to have these accusations made and one
of the defenses we've heard from him
what they believe is a silver bullet for
lawsuit number three it's actually a
boomerang because it shows
that on his radar screen for these
massages was the possibility of the
massage is becoming something more than
that which is the gist of the complaints
that have been made against him he just
claims in one case it was consensual
it bolsters the other 15 who are saying
that he was looking for something more
than just a massage
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports